♪ ♪
>> Laura: CALL IT THE GREAT
AMERICAN COVER UP BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN TELLING YOU FOR A FEW WEEKS
THAT THE KNIVES WERE OUT FOR
BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRAT PARTY,
BUT THE NEW PIECE IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" FOCUSES ON
THE AGE AND THE PERFORMANCE.
WE WILL SEE HOW RAPIDLY THINGS
ARE FALLING APART.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS FACING AN
ALARMING LEVEL OF DOUBT WITH 67%
OF VOTERS SAID THEY WOULD PREFER
A NEW STANDARD-BEARER IN 20 DUTY
FOUR.
NOW THE OLDEST PRESIDENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY AND THE
CONCERNS ABOUT HIS EIGHT RANKED
AT THE TOP OF THE LIST FOR
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS WHO WANT TO
FIND AN ALTERNATIVE.
THE TIMES WENT ON TO SPEAK TO A
NUMBER OF VOTERS INCLUDING
NICOLE FERRIER, A PRESCHOOL
TEACHER FROM MICHIGAN SAYING I
DON'T WANT SOMEBODY WILL
KNOCKING ON DEATHS DOOR.
ANOTHER BIDEN VOTER FROM
NEW YORK IS QUOTED AS SAYING DO
YOU EVER SEE HIM ON TV?
HE COMPARED THE PRESIDENT TO
ZOMBIES AND THAT'S WHEN HE LOOKS
LIKE.
WHY IS IT JUST COMING TO LIGHT
NOW?
WE'VE BEEN DOCUMENTING THE
FOOLISHNESS SINCE HE ANNOUNCED
HIS RUN IN 2019.
WHICH BEGS THE QUESTION WHAT DID
THE MEDIA KNOW AND WHEN DID THEY
KNOW IT?
OBVIOUSLY THE PRESIDENT KNOWS A
LOT MORE THAN THEY'RE TELLING US
ABOUT HOW BAD THINGS ARE INSIDE
THE WHITE HOUSE.
BUT THEY'RE NOT REPORTING
ANYTHING THEY KNOW BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT AFRAID OF HELPING THE
G.O.P.
THIS IS SCANDALOUS BECAUSE WE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW WHETHER BIDEN IS
CAPABLE OF ACTUALLY CARRYING OUT
THE DUTIES OF THE OFFICE.
JOINING ME NOW IS CHARLIE HURT,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
"WASHINGTON TIMES" OPINION
EDITOR.
CHARLIE, THE MEDIA IS ONLY
SOURING ON BIDEN BECAUSE THEY
SEE WHERE THE VOTERS ARE, RIGHT?
THE VOTERS ARE READY TO DUMP HIM
IN THE MEDIA SEEMS CLOSER TO
WANTING TO DUMP HIM, CORRECT?
>> ALSO JOE BIDEN SERVED HIS
PURPOSE.
THEY REALIZED NOW HOW TOXIC HE
HAS BECOME, WHAT A PROBLEM HE
IS.
THE GUY CAN'T RIDE A BICYCLE
WHICH IS A REAL PROBLEM.
SO THEY'RE STARTING TO TURN ON
HIM BUT THEY REALIZE THAT THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE CARRIED
FORWARD VERY WELL.
BUT THE ONE MISTAKE ABOUT YOU
JUST SAID, WE HAVEN'T BEEN
RECORDING HIS DODDERING
FOOLISHNESS SINCE 2019, WE'VE
BEEN REPORTING IT FOR DECADES.
HE WAS A BUFFOON ON
CAPITOL HILL.
IT'S BECOMING SO MUCH MORE
OBVIOUS.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THAT HE'S
SO OLD, A LOT OF US FEEL SORRY
FOR IT.
>> Laura: I DON'T, I FEEL
SORRY FOR THE COUNTRY.
YOU CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS IN
RETIREMENT.
NO, I FEEL SORRY FOR THE
COUNTRY, SUFFERING BECAUSE OF
THIS.
TODAY POLITICAL IS REPORTING
THAT THE LEFT WING GROUP THAT
WORKED IN THE 2020 ELECTION AND
PERSUADE PROGRESSIVE VOTERS TO
SUPPORT BIDEN NOW IS PREPARING
TO TURN OUT ON HIM AS WELL.
ROOTS ACTION WITH AN EMAIL LIST
OF 1.2 MILLION VOTERS AND PLANS
TO SPEND SIX FIGURES ON A
HASHTAG DON'T RUN JOE CAMPAIGN.
ADDITIONAL AD STARTING ONE DAY
AFTER THE MIDTERMS.
I CAN HEAR THE QUACKING ALREADY,
BUT THIS IS THE LAMEST OF THE
LAME DUCKS.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SOUND
SURPRISED, BUT THEY'RE LOOKING
AT BIDEN AND THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF LONGEVITY IN THIS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LOOKING UP AND
SAYING THE PRESIDENT LOOKS OLD
AT THE MOMENT AND EVEN AMERICANS
65 AND OLDER TO THE TUNE OF 62%
ARE SAYING THAT THIS IS NOT A
CANDIDATE FOR US ANYMORE.
IT'S NOT JUST HIS AGE AND THE
FACT THAT HE HAS A CLEAR MEDICAL
DECLINE, BUT HE'S BEEN A
GOVERNMENT FOR NEARLY 50 YEARS
NOW.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN THE LATEST
"NEW YORK TIMES" OPINION PIECE
REFER TO OUR GOVERNMENT AS A --
A PROBLEM TO SEE SO MANY PEOPLE
OF THE AGE DISCONNECTED FROM
REAL AMERICAN LIFE AND SIT IN
GOVERNMENT.
>> Laura: CHARLIE, THE HILL IS
REPORTING TONIGHT ON WHAT
THEY'RE CONTEMPLATING AS A
DOOMSDAY POLITICAL SCENARIO FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
OKAY, IT'S TAKING SHAPE.
THEY'RE NOW GOING BACK AND
SAYING WE THOUGHT WE COULD HOLD
ONTO THE SENATE.
BUT THAT'S LOOKING BAD NOW
BECAUSE BIDEN IS DRAGGING DOWN
THE WHOLE PARTY EVEN IN SOME
RACES WHERE YOU MIGHT HAVE BEEN
HAVING SOME TROUBLE.
THOSE ARE TIGHTENING.
DO YOU SEE THAT AS WELL?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT'S REMARKABLE IS THAT FROM
30,000, THE REPUBLICANS IN
SENATE IS THE WORST MAP OF THE
EVERY TWO YEAR CYCLE FOR
UNITED STATES SENATE.
THIS IS THE WORST MAP THAT
REPUBLICANS CAN FIX.
THE ONE THAT THEY FACE IN TWO
YEARS FROM NOW, AND FOUR YEARS
FROM NOW IS MUCH BETTER, BUT TO
EVEN GOING AGAINST THE MASSIVE
HEADWIND, IT LOOKS LIKE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO HAVE A
REAL HARD TIME HOLDING ONTO THE
SENATE.
THE SINGLE PERSON WHO'S TO BLAME
FOR THAT MORE THAN ANYBODY ELSE
IS JOE BIDEN.
THE BAR WAS SO LOW FOR HIM WHEN
HE CAME INTO OFFICE, ALL HE HAD
TO DO WAS UNIFY THE COUNTRY AND
INSTEAD, HE'S WRECKED THE
COUNTRY, WRECKED THE ECONOMY.
MADE A MESS OF FOREIGN AFFAIRS
WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE HIS AREA
OF EXPERTISE.
HE'S BEEN THE REIGNING EXPERT ON
FOREIGN POLICY IN WASHINGTON FOR
50 YEARS.
>> Laura: HERE'S WHAT KAMALA
SAID ABOUT 2020.
WATCH.
>> CAPITOL HILL, THERE IS
SPECULATION AMONG DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
WILL NOT RUN FOR REELECTION IN
2024.
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO THOSE WHO
SAY THAT?
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN INTENDS TO
RUN.
IF HE DOES, I INTEND TO WIN WITH
HIM.
>> Laura: KAMALA HOW
CONVINCING WAS THAT?
>> SHE IS NOT CONVINCING EVER,
SHE IS JUST AS BAD ON CAMERA AS
HE IS, BUT SHE CAN'T USE HER AGE
AS AN EXCUSE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
I DON'T THINK WE ARE GOING TO
SEE HIM RUNNING AGAIN.
IF WE DO, OH, MY GOSH, WE ARE IN
FORCE IN TROUBLE.
>> Laura: CHARLIE, WHEN YOU
THINK THIS THROUGH, THE
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE TO EMERGE
WITH SOME WORKING-CLASS
CONNECTIONS.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
WORKING CLASS DEMOCRATS
SUDDENLY.
TRY IT OUT IN PENNSYLVANIA WHO'S
ABOUT AS WORKING CLASSES ANY
TRUST FUND KID BUT THAT WILL NOT
WORK.
HE'S A BIG PHONY.
>> THEY ARE NO LONGER -- THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO PRETEND
REPRESENTING THE WORKING CLASS.
SAME THING THAT LED TO JOE BIDEN
IN 2020 FOR THE NOMINATION ARE
STILL AT PLAY NOW BECAUSE THE
PARTY HAS MOVED SO FAR AWAY FROM
THEIR ROOTS.
REMEMBER THE REPUBLICAN AD OR
THE AD SHOWED THEM WHEELING
GRANNY OFF THE CLIFF?
THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA AND
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING TO JOE BIDEN
NOW.
THEY'RE TRYING TO WIELD
JOE BIDEN IN A WHEELCHAIR OFF
THE CLIFF, ANYTHING TO GET RID
OF THEM BECAUSE THEY CANNOT WIN
WITH HIM